If it's actually, like this whole thing is still dicking with me—waAUGHAH
Hello, everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome back to
thREE ScArY GaMes *dramatic zoom*
This one's called Penumbra, and it's just uh, some—whoa oh
ohh
Oh, okay
Oooh
Alright, hey a coin!
alright
Woohoohoo, Hey, wait a minute
This IS like Penumbra (not like thats the name of this game or anything)
because Penumbra started out in the Arctic and you went in a hatch to go into a base
with like caves and stuff.
Interesting, (pause) oh
*zoom-in for emphasis* ssspooky
Ooh hello, oh shadow. Alright, you got it, baby. Thanks for the hint.
Ooh, Oh
My goodness you—that was a great drawing of this very room
Well, it's a pillar
It's a big old pillar and
uh *ping* ooh
Pardon?
Oh wait, this is drawing here. Wait.
Oh go round and ring around the ros—
Oh what the hell?
(Amazed) Wha- wait a minute. Wa-wait, wait a minute. Wait a minute
*he hella confused* *I love going around in circles :)*
Oh
Okay, that's weird, okay, that's weird. (Mark has never seen stairs before)
Oh hi. Okay, that's funky. Ah, oh
Two times
OH oh, oh, um, oh, OH
Oh, whOa, wHoa. Whoa *might as well be a siren* Oh
*some more O's*
Okay, okay
All right
Well, that was a fun pillar. I've never played a game of—
wAUHH nO no NO, no, nO, no, NO, no, No, no, no NO, no, Nooo
*basically asdfghjkl*
okay, that's fine. Yeah, uh, hi. How ya— Hey, whoa uGHhh
Okay, NO
All right gonna run for it, I guess. Well, I don't like that at all. That was not good
But I seem to be okay for now *yeah right*
Oh no
uh oh
Wait, no. Hey, what? Hey, wait a minute, where am I? Oh, hey
*actual gibberish*
Oh, oh, okay. This is messed up
This is so weird. Oh, that's a building . Oh god. I thought it was just lights
(Buildings have lights Mark)
Uh-huh. Okay. I probably missed some coins here and there I don't know if getting coins is like absolutely mandatory to beating this game
But I have not been getting those
Oookay
This is weird. Oh, okay. All right, um go round and round
Where it stops nobody knows~
Oh that's bright. Man that hurts my eyes. Oh my god
Okay, ohhh
Hey up there, howdy-do? I don't know if I'm going the right way
Was a clockwise or counterclockwise? Why are my eyes dusty, too? *See an optometrist, that seems bad*
Oh wait, what? Wait, what wait
Wait what? *le gasp*
No, no, noO, nOOO
This game does dicking with me so good. This game dicks me so good
*he says that like it means something*
How does this keep—daAUGH NOO
How's this game doing that? How are you doing that?? it's so well-hidden. It's so well done!
That's really well done. Oh, I hate this but okay, let's go. Let's go baabyy Oh,
knock knock?
Don't shush, please don't shush. I don't like the shushing.
Can I come in? Alright, I'll leave then
I'll leave
I'll go I'll—oh I can't go never mind.
*bANG* wAUGH I diDN't waNt aNyTHing
I don't want anything
*dank, spoopy corridor music*
Oh
Hate (x4) that
HI wAOw
That's not so good. Um, all right. Well, it's back up then. Oh waOW
Shit Oh, Oh God. Um, okay. No, lookie uh, uh, no, lookie. Oh god. No, lookie I guess
Oh, no, lookie. No lookie *stammers* I'm not looking, I would never look
Lookie is not what I do. I no lookie, I've never been look. I've never looked in my life
Looking—it's gonna be really hard to go through this maze, if it's just constantly like real dickish—YeAUGhh
If it's actually like this whole thing is still dicking with me
waAUGH oHH GAaWD
I've been my brain oot-ed (?) *what the actual fuck did you say?*
all right. Well, I'm dead
Oh no, I'm live
I guess being in bright, lit up areas is the bad thing. Oooh shit
Okay
Nope
bWAHH mah brAIN
Okay, let me read this note again. Alright, uh, can't see—oh and if you're under something
Okay, it's it's blind, it's not deaf. It's blind, maybe? I don't know. Oh no hide under the uh,
Okay that covered—the cover to cover to cover. I can't no don't anything but this
nWOAHH
Okay. All right. Got it. The maze has been solved by my brain. *Yes, Mark. That is how thinking works* Okay. I-I see it already. I see it
Okay. All right. I got it. Okay. There's actually a faint line of what it's supposed to be anyway, so
helpful
Nah, nah, nah, eHeheh, nah, nah, nah
No, no, nO. That's right. That's right, get out
oOH nope, that's unpleasant. But this is a weird change of pace in the game. I'm not sure if I like it, too mu—
I hate it. I hate it. I hate it. I hate yOU NOO
Alright never mind, I don't want to complain about the game at all, ever again. Game is fine
Game is fine and dandy
It's both fine. And so dandy
Euugh, it really wants to hang around this area
Really do. OOh
hey, we—how you doing? hey, ya doin?
Gunning it (x6)
Oh shit (x4)
We're fine, baby. We're fiNe. We're fine. We're so good. Oh shIT- We're nOt gOoD. WE'rE nOt goOd
Okay, we're good. We're good. We're good. We're good, we're good, we're good, okay
Um, I think I need to go that way wrap around again. And then we're good. Then we are good. Okay. No, you tricky!
Can't trick me like that!
No, no, don't come back. No, no, no, no
Okay, this is not the right way...no, it is, okay. This is the right way. Man
How did I avoid it that first time? Because I was not doing it right. I was definitely not doing it, right. Okay
Straight shot to the end, come on—
nuUOOH
I made it. I made it. I'm going for it. Whatever that is
I'm going for thank you. All these children's drawings guiding my path
*sigh of relief* Okay. Oh, ahhh
All right, run arou—I know it said the other way, but I want to run around this way just to see what happens
Ahh the note goes away for you that way. All right this way
Round and round and round I go~
Where I'll stop?~
Nobody knows~
It's not working. Maybe it was this way. Maybe the drawing was wrong
Maybe like, I've just had some crazy drug trip down in the basement, and I'm just out in the cold running around a pillar
and like "Guys! Guys! It's crazy! This pillar's just—it's nuts! It's
bonkers! just run around it. Hey come on! Hurry up! You're gonna miss it!"
I'm just a fool running in a circle forever and ever until I die of cold
Well, I feel real dumb right now
I feel really silly. Oh, I know what I need to take my clothes off, of course
(put them pole-dancing skills to use)
I need to take all my pants off. *Wait, what?* Oh of course, duh. How could I be so smart? Hahaha gotta take it. Yeah
there we go. Alright, I don't know what's happening
Oh wait the tent wasn't there before. That's what—
*Wilford Warfstache appears*
I'm, ohhhh
*Insane Warfstache Laughter*
Ohhh me, oh my
I'm...okay. Alright
*Insane Warfstache Laughter part 2*
*OK Warfstache we get it!*
*Is this Darkiplier?*
*Nope, still insane Wilford without his pink moustache*
*Wilford's mad cackles*
*Wilford's gone Joker levels insane*
*Go home Wilford, you're drunk*
Alright we're out. Okay, I didn't know how long that was gonna go *giggles* *BYE WILFORD*
This one is called
I've already forgotten. *Great title!*
This one's called Belly. Literally just called Belly *Eh, could use some work*
WaOw, what in–Oh?
what?
what? *pt. 2*
oOh *nervous chuckle*
hYAH *attac* Ohh what the...?
hyah
(Squeaky) whatisthat?
(Squeaky) oohhhnooo
(Squeaky) I got it
hwat?
*high pitched* what the hell?
*even higher* ohmygod
This is so weird, what is happening??
what is that? What am I looking at?
Am I really in a belly?
Ow, I got hit. Oh, how am I supposed to reflect all these?
Ow, oh, owie. I don't kno—
This is so weird. Hello buddy, how are you? oh my godstayaway
*pathetic climax*
Don't shoot your weird sperm things at me
Oh my god, this is the weirdest thing
wHat is ThiS? whAt is HaPpeNing?
Uwahhhh get awayy, you naked mole—wHAT'Re YoU??
hOOhHH mY GOdd
Oh nooo, no, no no no no
No, no, no, no none of that. Oh hi again
what is happening?? Oh what was that?
I don't know, man. This is so weird
Oh boy and dead, alright, oops, sorry
Oh boy, alright and on the move again, I feel I feel particularly
Uncomfortable about this one. *you and me both, Mark* Oh
Hey buddies, hey how you doing?
hey how ya doin?
Also, what am I? That, that's a whole other question, like what am I?
Some horrible parasite? Maybe I shouldn't—maybe this is like the body's immune system and—oh
hYAAhh
HyaAAHh
hyaahh, oh shit, oh wow
Geezums, is there an end to this? I mean it said there was a leaderboard—oh wait at the bottom
there's like some kind of progress thing
Whoa, what is that?
What is that? I don't know what that is
Okay
Can I have that? Oh shit
Ohhoho
Okay, good for me. Oh my god. Oh my god
All right. There we go
Somehow we're still alive
Whoa, whoa. Hey, ooookay
Wow
That was really weird. That was super weird
That was weird
Okay, I think once is enough for that one though
That was a looong progress bar at the bottom and I don't feel like going through that whole thing
Cuz that would take, like, an hour to get through that whole bar. Ah, I'm okay
I for one, aM oKAy
This next one by SMN MHMDY Productions
"Dim is a completely sound based experience play with headphones." Really?
and put your system sound as loud as you can tolerate. Alright
Oh shit
We're in. "This is a playable demo for an upcoming horror game. The demo takes place in a small part of a house
where you play as an unnamed protagonist with a very specific backstory that makes him know what is going on.
Well him, not you. Explore the house, look for clues and experience this small ten minutes playable demo."
Ahh good old unnamed protagonist with a backstory. "The ball."
"Ah, I should probably find that cross first"
Oh, of course. The cross. *The power of Christ compels you!*
Where's the cross?
We're getting like Grandma levels of graphics here. Oh, "Oh god, please *giggles*"
Oh
God
Lord please Lord
Descend your music to help me. "The door's here, but it looks weak. Maybe I could push through it"
Okay, I don't know why those chains are, undulating like that. But alright
hello
Ah, I am booshing through it
Oh
Hi?
*Giggley*Oookay
Oh, wow, this flashlight is pretty
Pretty room level. Okay. Alright. Okay. Alright
Okay *oof, noises*
okay
"Maybe the water is behind this door...I should find a way in"
*spoopy radio transmission*
*SCP: Containment Breach flashbacks*
Right, okay
Glad that happened. So I got to find a way to get around the door
Do I get a crowbar? Or something of the like? This tomato soup or is it blood? I see cans there, could be tomato soup
I have no idea what's going on a lot of cigarettes. Just lying about
Whyyyy did you do that? You want to run that by me again??
Also, were you there before? Because I feel like I would have noticed you
Oh
"Where it belongs"
Where 'what' belongs? The ball?
You're talking about the ball? Do I need to go back for the ball?
Ohh the ball is not there anymore, where'd the ball go? The ball!—wait
Wait a minute, alright it's probably fine. Hey the ball. Yeah, that's the ball, alright
okay, I'm gonna I just—I've screwed myself haven't I?
*Mark being Mark*
Just playing some soccer or football~ Oh now I've gotten it stuck (shocker)
I uh *actual gibberish*
Having some trouble here, gettin it away from like the wall, ya know?
Just, can I please? All I want is to get it. No, not in the...
This is...
Oh boy, the door is blocked, so is the ball. Oh boy—this, they didn't think this through.
They did—Oh my god did not think this through. Okay. Here we go. We're on a rol—
No nO NO NO God, damn you. Okay. All right...
Uhhhh
move, okay, and there we go. All right. Here we go. We're on a roll  this time
This time, we're gonna get this. Nope? Uh what?
*static sounds ft. confused Mark*
*static fades*
Hello? OH, it's open, okay, I was close enough *chuckles* Partial credit
*spoopy sound*
OH
Hey, how you doin—aAUGH fffff
FUucking heelll
All right
*intense closeup* cOOL
That's fine. "No water here." No water here. I sure am thirsty!
Just got a hankering for some some water. Just need a little bit of water
Just a slight
sloosh of water, please. A little bit
A splish— *that's a face*
"Great the generator went down"
That is great. I wouldn't have thought that a place this
Uh
Decrepit would need a generator. Oh, okay. That's that's probably fine. Where's the generator by the way? I never knew that
so
*queue another facial expression*
You want to run that by me again? *Is that your catchphrase?*
Also, is this my house? Cause if it is, I have many concerns
about you know—ooUF
Y-you sack of shIT? Oh, you think that's gonna scare me? NoOO
(it just did)
No, I can do that too
oHOhhohoHHHhohh *just Mark things*
Yeah, it's practically the same. All right, well, I don't know where the generator is but uh
Doesn't seem to be here
So I guess I'm just gonna go back and forth until it shows me what it wants me to see so, you know
I'm gonna do that. Ooh, is this new?
"You're not going anywhere. You know that right? And get rid of the stupid cross. Don't make me angry."
oH, alright, well
Nahh, I'm okay. Oh shit
*henlo*
Hey whoa, whoa, hey, hey
Uhghh
Don't like that
*Giggley* Oookay, that's the end of it
Un Sun MHNDY Game
"It was just a glimpse of our final product."
Honestly, not bad, but
Juuust a little—
*oof that's a sound*
Just a little unpolished. Like there those scares
they got me good (real good)
But overall I didn't take the whole game
Like the whole game from the get-go didn't get, like get me immersed into it in a serious way. It just seemed very, uh-
I-it's it's not that it wasn't serious or anything like that
It's just like the game itself didn't lead me to really buy into it because it was just a bit too
Unfocused. Do you know what I mean? Anyway, I don't have too many criticisms about the game. It was fine
It scared me and is good. With more polish, it will go a long way. So, it just needs a bit more polish
So not bad, not bad.
That was 3 Scary Games (#18, jfc). Very scary, very fun
I appreciate it a lot, and I appreciate you guys being here to watch along
So thank you everybody so much for watching
Check out the other scary games that I played in the link in the description below to the scary games playlist
And as always, I will see you, in the next video.
bUh-bYe 👋